rape as a weapon
has the world failed to protect women
our guest today is monica hauser founder
of the organization medical mondiale
which helps traumatized women and girls
who live in war zones and conflict
regions
hello hello
welcome to the dw interview
i'm alexandra fornamen
this topic has been in the news recently
with the brutal attacks by islamic state
forces in syria and iraq
thousands of women many of them yazidis
have been kidnapped raped and sold into
slavery
why do men do this
there's a huge problem right now with
sexual violence around the world
but only some incidents make the
headlines
there's also a lot of violence in
so-called peaceful states
where people live in patriarchal
societies
of course in conflict zones sexual
violence can be used strategically to
achieve certain goals
to demoralize entire populations to
humiliate degrade or intimidate them
but women are raped in these situations
simply because the men have weapons
and they can do whatever they want
that's a pretty somber evaluation you've
been dealing with this problem for more
than 20 years are you surprised that
these things are still happening
i'm not surprised that they do
we've been dealing with these situations
for 22 years
other activists have been working a lot
longer than that to stop violence
against women
i know what the reality is
i read reports mostly from syria but
also from the democratic republic of
congo and other conflict regions
the details in these reports are simply
appalling
for example
i become extremely upset when i read
about the rape of young girls
it's a clear indication of how brutal
these men can be
they dehumanize their victims because
they themselves have become dehumanized
have your experiences and research in
this field changed your image of men in
general
i had always had a very critical image
of men so for me that's nothing
at the same time i think that people are
not born brutal or violent
their behavior is dictated by
circumstances
i believe that a lot has gone wrong in
this world in the last 20 or 30 years
especially as a result of the west's
reaction to the 9 11 attacks
a lot of young men throughout the arab
world have been treated brutally and
they have no hope for the future
still it is the patriarchal systems
worldwide that create opportunities for
men to behave like this
your primary goal is to help women
who've been subjected to violence you've
launched a new project in northern iraq
tell us about that
we provide support for women and girls
who are traumatized by their experiences
this includes direct psychological
medical and legal support
we also help local caregivers to develop
new skills
we're doing that right now in the doha
region of northern iraq in cooperation
with the kurdish government there
these local caregivers are often the
first people that these women turn to
many of the victims are yasidis the
caregivers include doctors nurses and
psychologists and these people need
training so that they can deal properly
with the victims
they have to learn how to provide
support and they must do it with the
utmost care
and not make things worse
so most of the caregivers don't have any
experience dealing with these kinds of
victims these
qualifications
very few people do i'm sorry to say that
even in western countries like germany
many of those who deal with refugee
women don't have this kind of training
that situation has got to
it's also important to train local
caregivers in conflict zones because
entire societies have been traumatized
and will stay that way for a long time
if we can provide trained personnel to
help them
it will have a positive effect over time
you've been working with female victims
of violence for more than 20 years in
1992 you heard about incidents of mass
rape during the bosnian war and decided
to go there to help
that was a radical step
what was your primary motivation
but when i read these reports i realized
that i had to do something
i was angry about what was being done to
women there and angry that the
international community and the aid
organizations were doing nothing to help
them
and i was angry about the neurid reports
that i saw in the media
i felt that this situation affected me
personally and that i had to go to
bosnia and do what i could to help those
women
and once you got there was there a
particular person or event that had a
real impact on you
i remember the entire year of 1992-93
quite well
i sometimes felt like a war veteran
because i realized that i too had been
traumatized by living and working in a
war zone
i simply cannot forget what i saw and
experienced there
i still have vivid memories of meeting
nurses who worked at a hospital in
zenika in central bosnia
they really wanted to work with me many
of the patients were bosnian muslim
women who'd managed to escape the
fighting
some were pregnant and wanted an
abortion
but the chief physician wouldn't allow
it
the nurses talked to these women and
learned that many others had committed
suicide
the nurses decided that these women
needed a special facility where they
could feel safe
and get the psychological and medical
support that they needed
you mentioned that you also felt
traumatized at this time how did you
deal with your situation
were you able to put those horrific
stories out of your mind at the end of
the day
no i didn't want to become cynical or
just go through the motions
i've seen that happen to a lot of other
people in this profession
that means that when you've come through
a particularly difficult situation you
can't keep looking back at what happened
you'll feel like you're on a treadmill
you have to deal with it bit by bit
and quite often your response is based
on your own experience and your own
feeling of powerlessness
so it's important for those of us who do
this kind of work every day to pause
occasionally and reflect
what role do we play and how can we
protect ourselves
but it's also important for us to
understand why we do this work
much of my motivation comes from the
fact that my colleagues and i want to
make the world a better place for women
i've met women all around the world in
liberia congo bosnia afghanistan
and we talk about these successes and
failures in our work
we're doing this not only for ourselves
but also for our daughters to change
things in this world you've got to stick
together and we believe strongly that
every time we help a woman in need it
makes the world a better place
so that situations such as in northern
iraq where women are raped abducted and
enslaved no longer happen
it's a very sad situation and i am
disappointed by the response of the
international community
for 22 years we've been reporting on the
fate of women in war zones
right now we're working on a report that
indicates that many bosnian women are
still suffering from psychological
trauma 22 years after the fact
they are outcasts in their own society
so it's a double trauma if you will
the un has drafted proposals and germany
has signed them
but no one appears willing to stand up
and take action to change the situation
some people have come up with good ideas
but where does the money end up
what are the priorities in this society
and as far as weapons exports are
concerned germany for example is selling
weapons to saudi arabia and other
countries in conflict zones
and that won't help improve the
situation of women there
and in these unstable conflict zones
there's an increase in the number of
rapes and that just makes the situation
worse
what specific recommendations would you
make
there's got to be substantial changes in
foreign security and defense policy
we have to take measures to prevent
conflict and that means not selling
weapons to ukraine or saudi arabia
what we need
is more diplomacy and the situation of
women in conflict zones must be
monitored more closely
also women should be given a role in
peace negotiations and it's tragic that
women haven't been given more of a say
in how refugee camps are run
for example there have been incidents of
sexual slavery in syria and adjacent
countries
that wouldn't happen if women were
allowed to help administer the camps
we've known about these problems for
years but no one does anything about
them
there have been lots of fine proposals
but people don't have the political will
to carry them out and i'm still waiting
for the german government to do more to
help women in conflict zones
einstein
finally we ask our interview guests to
complete a series of three sentences
first
when my son talks about my work he says
he loves it and hates it when i go to
afghanistan he hates it because it's
dangerous for me but he also loves it
because he knows it's my job
chancellor merkel were to call me today
and offered to grant me one wish i'd say
i'd like to take her to see our work in
conflict zones if she could see that
maybe she'd change her policy priorities
in the politics
my colleagues and i would dissolve our
women's aid organization
we won't see that in our lifetime
we'll stop our work only when there is
no more sexual violence against women
that's our vision
we keep working even though we know that
we won't reach our goal
monica thank you my pleasure